miles how many times did you get punched
in the face for the film over one less
than 100 okay yeah I couldn't tell what
was it like the first time versus the
hundredth the first time shocking second
they're not shocking but first times
like yeah it's yes we'll say a little
shocking and then after that it's like
ok now I'm okay you got yours i'm gonna
give you mine Aaron where were you in
your life when this role for Kevin
Rooney was presented to uh I was right
here in those entities and I met Ben the
director came and saw me and presented
this to me miles and I had worked
together before on a movie called rabbit
hole and so I was happy to reunite with
him and I loved the story i love the
comeback story i love the guy that
dreams big i love the the family element
in this you know the sacred bond of
trainer fighter so I was and I love
boxing so I was very happy to do it
Katie did you audition for the role of
Louise Vinny passes mom um I sort of
auditioned I uh been approached me and
got the script to me and we had
conversation about the part and we had
several conversations and then it was
kind of a mutual decision that I should
come in I said let me come in and read
and let's make sure it's right and so we
did and so yes it didn't really feel
like not edition but I think it was an
audition yes did you happen to see your
own self in Vinnie Paz his life in his
story I did very much what was that I
had I've been 12 years as I've made a
movie and in Hollywood that's a very
long time to not work for and similar to
vinia I was had there were suggestions I
might not make another movie in the way
that there were suggestions made to him
that he might not fight again once I
sort of realized that parallel strange I
didn't when the story was pitched to me
but once I got into writing it realized
oh wait this is my story that's when I
decided to stay on and direct originally
was just a writing assignment were there
parts of vinny passes life in term
of his rise and then stalled out for a
little bit with the accident that
reminded you of anything in your own
life or yeah well I mean I think with
Vinnie Vinnie had his family support
Vinnie also his sport was boxing my
sport was baseball baseball was
something that you know I remember even
in high school I was doing as a freshman
I would be the guy going to two days
with the seniors Raj I'd go to high
school at a you know 5 30 and when run
laps and do all that stuff like if I had
the talent and baseball that's something
I would have given everything to I think
sports for me just the discipline and
kind of the you know the ethics of the
games or it was something that I really
associated with can we talk about being
in the Edit room and cutting back
between footage from your film and the
real life Vinnie Paz because you did it
so seamlessly that there are hearts that
you don't know if it's miles if it's
Benny love hearing you say that yeah
that was not by design the truth is that
we just thought we would used archival
footage for the end credits but when
miles sort of completed his
transformation he got so close to Vinnie
his likeness the way sounds that when we
got the editing room we've said let's
just let's try him let's try and cut
directly to the archival footage in the
middle the movie which should take
people out of the film and didn't and
that's a testament to miles and the
preparation work that he did where did
you go inside of your own experiences to
develop or work on the character of
Kevin well I mean you know boxers or you
know they're the sacrifice dedication
discipline you know I find that I have
that my own life with my own career you
know it takes a fighter's mentality to
you know to work in this business and we
share that and then I went to a local
trainer here one of the greatest
trainers in the world Freddie Roach and
I went through Manny Pacquiao and vs.
Bradley their training camp and Freddie
taught me everything he knows about
about being a trainer whispering in the
ear doing the myths you know giving him
water the chess game that you play so I
got a pretty good good education and
then I found unfortunately Kevin Rooney
is in the hospital
with dementia and so I wasn't able to
work with him but I worked with his son
and I learned as much as I could about
him and and put it on screen how was it
for you to play this version of a mother
is I have to say at first I didn't even
know it was you it was so different from
other roles I've seen right it was great
I mean I like to play very different
roles and I had sort of the the pictures
of her the the picture that was written
in the script of her as well as physical
footage I had of her made it easy to
kind of fall into what that would be and
I loved working on the accent I loved
having a different I'd like to transform
I like all that and I know that from the
press notes I believe it said that
Louise didn't drive she was pretty much
homebound yes wouldn't smoke in front of
any so that must have been very very
different from some of the other mothers
that you played how was it to kind of
keep all this stuff internal and then
when you're done shooting kind of go
back to you I mean it just seemed like
it was a lot of constraint right well
you know it's interesting I I think
there's a part of me as a mother because
I have three children of my own that is
a little bit naturally constraint around
wanting to know where my kids are at so
what I know about raising kids is
sometimes you have to contain yourself I
mean for me so that they can show you
who they are so it wasn't that difficult
really and actually in my own life I'm
pretty constraint well I was gonna ask
you to how done very well no oh go not
at all the red wig was just one part of
that red okay no that's not who I am I
was wondering how you balance all that
because you're a performer your singer
actress wife mother houses work balance
what what's the best recommendation oh
that situation just do what's in front
of you sort of you know um you know it's
gotten easier over the years I don't I
try not to travel to too often because I
do have a little one also and you know
it's all it's all good is what I always
tell myself it's all you know and it all
gets done well I know you did many
things
between that yeah I'm after Prime yeah
did you get an airline I got my pilot's
license yeah I'm not an ATP I can't fly
passengers but I can fly myself and
friends I mean I can't I'm not like an
airline pilot right yeah I'm private
pilot but but do you feel that was in
some ways beneficial for you because or
maybe not you were able to stand back
and reevaluate things and now look what
you've created it's amazing yeah no
totally I've I know people that I've
left New York or and come to LA to be
screenwriters and they do lose a little
something there is there is something to
be said for getting out and living in
the world being a part of the world and
having experiences interpersonal you
know communications between new people
and then that ends up finding its way on
screen even though I thought oh no all
my contemporaries are moving ahead
they're making all these movies while
i'm not i'm enjoying life but you know
in my is this going to set am I going to
suffer professionally but somehow it all
ended up on screen you said that you
want to be part of films that affect
people how do you feel that a Vinnie Paz
a story will affect viewers oh well I
think it's you know it's the greatest
comeback in sports but you know you
could even get rid of the word sports
it's just an incredible comeback is a
guy who faced really like impossible
odds and is the first person to ever do
that and I just think that it's a you
know it's inspiring store that's gonna
you know if people want to they can take
what he did and you know connected to
their own life and if they're feeling
tired they're feeling like they can't do
it and oh man it's just so hard well
look at what he did like how hard is
that and he still did it so like what
are you gonna complain about well I know
you've talked before i believe about
like dark and light characters and how
often the audience relates more to the
dark character because maybe they feel
more comfortable i think people you know
we're all riddled by fear and doubt and
insecurity and we all have dreams we
talk ourselves out of those dreams you
know that's what life's about adversity
and and those usually I mean people
could obviously relate to those
characters you know there
they're complex but they're also more
entertaining you know because they're
struggling and we like to you know this
is a comeback story so we want it we
like to see people who've been on the
top and a fallen-down fallen from grace
and then picking themselves back up I
would say there's no such thing as
second chances you get as many chances
as you want in this world it's what it's
how you present yourself to the world
that gives you the second chance you can
continually reinvent yourself but you've
got to do it and this is a story about
two guys and a whole family who who
picked themselves off the mat and
reinvent themselves it's about a guy who
gets in a car accident breaks his neck
and becomes a middleweight champion the
world afterwards and it's never been
done before so there's a lot of you know
good you know thematics going on in this
movie right how do you think people
relate to Kevin's character I think I
love him I think that he's a free spirit
he loves his fighter you know you can
see that they have a great love for each
other you know he has his demons you
know he's fighting his demons he's
living vicariously through Vinnie he's a
colorful guy I think they like him a lot
he's pretty funny excellent
transformation yeah yeah totally didn't
recognize you so thank you very much I
think that's the elephant in the room in
the industry is that people do have long
I wouldn't say dry spells but just for
lack of a better word and then something
fantastic happens so for you what advice
would you have two other people who
still want to be in the industry I think
you looked at Scripps right you kept
yourself active in terms of keeping a
foot in I kept we kept writing it in Rio
was I didn't read but I was wrote so I
would do script rewrites script
doctoring I sold a bunch of pilots
that's how I paid most largely paid my
bills so my advice would be similarly to
not stop writing if you're just a
director I actually I have empathy
because you're selling a skill set
that's not quantifiable but if you write
a screenplay and everybody somebody
wants it you have leverage you have you
own something a piece of property that
so I would say if you're a writer just
keep writing can we talk about striving
for
greatness and the isolation I know
you've talked about you enjoy Kobe
Bryant's documentary believe me yeah
yeah yeah that's what I was going to
talk yeah I was a good at vessels gonna
relate to Kobe and you know and he's
documentary talked about that like if
you really want to be great at something
you know maybe you can't be the best
friend or the best brother or the best
son are the best you know whenever like
it's a you know that quest for greatness
it is it's going to be a selfish journey
but if you look you'll get one chance at
this life so if you really want to give
everything to something then it's going
to be yeah it is going to be an isolated
journey you just have to be comfortable
with you know other areas other of your
life being sacrificed for that how are
you dealing with that these days because
so many things are coming your way
opportunities notoriety why God's good
bad good balance you know I have you
know I have a good family I've great
friends that I've known since I was like
14 15 I don't have to worry about how's
this guy gonna screw me over whatever
it's like now I've known these guys more
than half my life you know I've got a
great professional team of people around
me I've got a good girl like it's all um
I don't know I got enough things to kind
of still make me feel like myself
excellent thing thank you and lastly
maintaining in an industry that faces
people out and you've been able to
thrive yeah wild thoughts thoughts on
that super grateful um you know I I just
feel blessed about it that I continue to
work and that jobs come my way and and
and different and interesting kind of
jobs you know I feel like it keeps
getting you know I don't ascribe to the
fact that we as women as we get older
should be sort of disappearing and so
far I've been able to stay you know
viable so and I I maybe it's sort of
like Vinnie Paz I refuse to believe
otherwise you know Vinnie Paz believed
that he would box again I just believe
I'll keep working excellent thank you
thank you